gabriel matzneff ressorte de toi trois
livres en même temps cette camisole de
flamme journal chez folio comme le feu
mais les d'aromates à la table ronde et
les moins de 16 ans chez julliard mais
lors d'un coup trois breaks mais voilà
mets ça sur ma des vieux enfants
mais les éditeurs passent leur temps à
dire qu'un livre au bout d'un mois est
foutu et qu'il faut faire en fait c'est
vrai des mauvais livres à dire la
plupart des livres qui existent mais
quelqu'un qui écrit des beaux livres des
bons livres bien c'est comme le bon vin
ils sont encore meilleurs dix ans après
ou 15 ans avalant tout montre que les
rires parce que c'est quand même
beaucoup moins cher que quand c'est
sorti j'imagine oui puis non parce qu un
cher c'est pour moins cher surtout folie
en espagne certains ça c'est là à la
portée de toutes les bourses
je me suis intéressé à tanout is dans le
dans le dictionnaire de jérôme garcin le
dictionnaire des écrivains par eux-mêmes
et j'ai découvert dans globe enflé un
petit billet disons que tu as fait
utiliser nos débuts on devait être sans
pied à la fin on se retrouve 250 qui
sont les 150 autres alors qu'ils sont
les 150 authentique solaire de joueurs
du barça c'est à dire que jérôme est
parti en disant vous serez sans et puis
je pense que en se bourrant est un jeune
éditeur il a eu des coups de téléphone
eu des gens qui sont dans les maisons
d'édition des gens qui sont les prix
parce que les trois plupart des
écrivains sont des situations littéraire
sur les gens qui font comme moi qui
écris ne sont rien à part leur plume et
leur art d'écrire il y en a pas beaucoup
la plupart de ces gens sont placés alors
je pense qu'il ya un tas de membres des
jurys littéraires candy et new et c est
ce qui fait qu'on s'est retrouvé comme
dans le cid
nous partîmes 500 mais en arrivant au
port des larcins quand ils ont 250 dont
150 bringard même sûr en fait on aurait
dû être dispo c'est ce que tu fais tu
dis que tu es entré en littérature ce
que tout le monde c'est d'ailleurs par
un parent
et c'est qui traitait du suicide et que
tu finiras suicidé à manière que tu as
déjà bouclé la boucle
oui j'annonce mon suicide mais
contrairement à certains de nos états
d'âme il part en famille dans quelques
jours surtout que j'ai pas avec la
british airways comme tous les arabes
expulsés y avoir autre chose que tu dis
dans cette notice nécrologique bon que
tout le monde sait c'est que tu as
toujours préféré les filles au maire ça
ça fait partie des portes afin bouquin
qui s'appelle les mois de saison donc
tout le monde le sait c'était un
programme est un programme et que tu es
bien les fils à l'occasion surtout quand
j'étais très jeune oui j'étais vous
pouvez sans ciblage entre des petits
garçons mais je te dire que plus on
vieillit plus les jeunes filles on
comprime parfait ici finis les petits
garçons ben tu disais toute façon sur
tout ça c'est pour tout bien tout
honneur en fait visé puisque tu aimais
chez les petits garçons
c'était leur féminité et que finalement
les adolescents constituent le réel
troisième sexe c'est ça que tu dises à
l'adolescence est troisième sexe
beaucoup puisque les curés tu dis
toujours que des pédophiles mais pas
homosexuel que c'est pas la même chose
parce qu'il est pédophile c'est aimer
les petits enfants et nos sexualités
légende soulagé et content a lâché ont
des goûts très les grandes passions
c'est super ce soit prendre jusqu'à ou
vanessa et comment inspiré que
sincèrement avait 14 ans et 15 ans c'est
quand même pas prendre le pouvoir des
enfants mary daly maternelle c'est quand
même des jeunes filles par exemple qui
ont tout à fait l'âge des mais d'avoir
des à bondir au xviie siècle elle aurait
déjà été mariée
satire mais pas ça dit pas ce qu'ils
imaginent les gens qui me regardent ce
soir les aventures des sonates slam
c'est infernal
tu être vraiment choisi d'être en mars à
toi oui non mais quelqu'un qui veut
venir à la télévision à notre école pour
dire moi j'aime bien faire l'amour avec
les petites filles avec des petits
garçons dans le temps c'est toujours
très choquant c'est toujours très
scandaleux même au jour d'aujourd'hui tu
sais très bien et de plus en plus
choquant ah oui c'est simple et gentil
choquant parce que nous avançons vers la
vertu celle la fin du xxème siècle sera
extrêmement banlieusarde vertueuse et
est constipé
tu as dit je préfère ce qui me fait peur
c'est pas l'âge c'est la vache y semant
une très belle phrase très juste mais je
crois que je pense et ça dans le zen je
fais un peu jaser en amenant dans le zen
on t'apprend te positionner en fait je
crois que le petit tabouret tenait un
tout droit et bien je crois que c'est
moralement très important je crois c'est
une question d'attitude dans la vie il
faut et qu'on ait de l'argent quand on
n'est pas qu'on habite 1 ils sont
plusieurs
une question de rigueur de même qu'il
faut être frais il faut toujours valeur
de sortir de sa douche dans l'existence
et je n'aime pas la crasse morale et la
crasse de la machine éveil l'agissement
ton style est très rigoureux c'est ce
qui fait sa force et c'est pour ça qu'on
peut relire tous ces bouquins dont l'un
d'entre eux sortir en 69 le prend 74 et
c'est très rigoureux dans le style c'est
très près de dépouiller comme ça et
c'est pour ça que ça sur vire au bord de
l'abyme je crois qu'on peut se
rapprocher dix ans au point virgule quoi
on peut se raccrocher la langue
française
etaient-elles garde fou quand le
désespoir quand à mort contre la folie
quand tous les excès auxquels on peut
s'abandonner les uns les autres
12 ordres et quand on a la chance
d'avoir cet instrument de travail qu'à
la langue française c'est bien il faut
il faut en être fier il faut en profiter
en temps il faut en jouir pleinement se
passer on va faire un petit jeu tu
connais du portrait chinois
oui j'ai joué à ça quand j'avais moins
de 16 ans
si tu étais une injure une injure
allez vous faire [ __ ] c'est la même
que ce adverse exactement par gta
microbes
c'est pas l'arrivisme wayne site était
un poison le cyanure suicidaire comme
moi c'est un collabo 3 bat t rebatet car
j'admire beaucoup les deux étendards
quittant descendait un des plus grands
romans français du xxème siècle un
dictateur néron n'iront pourtant tu
connais bien les philippines kamel
passer du temps tu arrivé à tous filé
dans les tribunes de mal à marcos et
marcos n'ait pas été un producteur en or
more que c'était un très bon démocrate
marcoux c'est un grand calomnie à 10 par
mois je regrette marcos c'était un homme
extrêmement les mamans qui n'est aussi
qu'il fallait quelqu'un de germes en et
marcos avait un peu plus de branches
c'est marco c'était un n'est pas si
mauvais qu'on avait envie de dire tout
haut ce que les gens qui en parlent d'un
10/10 mal
marcos du marcos mais il marque ou
stéphanie créateurs non moi je reste un
héros est un vrai c'était un vice
non qu'elle prend
je dirais le voyez vis pour moi ça
serait d'abstinence ou alors on pourrait
dire l'ivrognerie parce que j'adore le
bon vin et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu